- Hi, good humans.
It's Milky.
I recently started feeling anxious
and overwhelmed by life's
day to day challenges.
Which is why I decided
to focus on bettering
my mental health and start
seeing a therapist again.
So, thank you to today's
sponsor, Better Help.
Better Help is making
professional therapy accessible,
affordable, and convenient
with a broad range of expertise
and a network of 20,000 plus therapists
so that anyone who struggles
with life's challenges
can get help anytime, anywhere.
First, you start by
filling out a questionnaire
to help access your specific needs.
Then get matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours.
From there, you can talk to your therapist
in private sessions on a
secure video or phone call
or Better Help offers unlimited messaging
with your therapist.
And all of this is
completely confidential.
My therapist at Better Help
has really taught me to give
compassion to myself and that
my anxiety doesn't define me.
Join me in the 2 million plus people
who have taken charge
of their mental health
with an experienced Better Help therapist.
Get 10% off your first month
at betterhelp.com/jubileemedia.
That's Better Help, H E L P,
dot com, slash Jubilee media.
Now, let's get into the video.
- [Interviewer] Do you think
your dad knows your type?
- No, I do not think he
knows my type at all.
- [Interviewer] We asked Tommy
to rank his daughter's potential
matches from worst to best.
Then we asked Tommy's daughter, Nikki,
to rank the men so we could
compare their results.
- I was a little shocked.
- What's the worst that could
happen? (guitar music playing)
(kissing sound)
- Can you please?
(all laughing)
My name is Tommy Tran.
Original came from Vietnam, got married,
have two children,
Nikki and Travis.
I mean, having them is a
wonderful thing we have in life.
- My name's Nikki.
I grew up in orange county, California
currently a full time
student in San Francisco.
- [Interviewer] Do you think
your dad knows your type?
- No, I do not think he
knows my type at all.
- Perfect guy for Nikki in my eyes.
We expecting family person,
not out there partying a lot.
Once in a while I'm okay with that,
but not every weekend.
Have their goal
like what's they looking for in the future
for themself and not
just for Nikki at first
because if they don't
have any goals, you lost.
- I'm still young, you know?
I'm looking for some fun, adventure
and I want someone who has
goals though, obviously,
but that's more of the future stuff.
Right now, I'm in really my
spontaneous phase, you know?
Gonna go with the flow,
see if we vibe.
Well, might as well
throw these in the fire.
(Law and Order dramatic sound plays)
- Hello.
- Hi.
- Nice to meet you, and your name is?
- Youssef.
- Youssef?
- Born and raised in Egypt.
Traveled around for a bit.
Ended up out here in California.
- Okay.
- I have some family still in Egypt.
I have family in England.
So we're kind of all spread out.
Been here for about six years.
I'm studying acting.
For fun I'll be surfing or skateboarding
or traveling around and...
- Adventure.
- Yeah. Exploring. Exactly
hanging out with friends-
- If you ever find a chance like
you just want to go and just pack
and take off without saying
anything or any to anybody?
- If I ever find the
chance will I take it?
- Yeah, I mean like... (men laughing)
- Adventure, when you
thinking like, "Okay,
I'm gonna go to like China
and just pack and go."
- This is a trick question.
- Without telling anybody.
You know? And like take off and disappear?
- See that right answer, I should say,
"No, I would never just leave
without telling anyone",
but I mean, backpacking in
China sounds kind of fun.
(all laughing)
So, I enjoy doing stuff with people.
- Okay.
- I think people is my favorite
part of traveling around.
- Okay. Now, so have you ever
been in any relationship?
- No.
I have not.
Now you get it. Yeah. (men laughing)
- And yourself.
- My name is Ben.
- Hi Ben.
- I was born and raised in Indiana
and I just finished my
junior year of college
at Ball State University.
I'm studying video production.
- Oh, wow.
- So, I'm out here
for the summer, finding video
jobs and stuff like that.
- Flew over here just looking
for your future or your...
- No, no, I drove, I made sure to...
- Oh, okay, okay.
- What's is your name?
- Wilson.
- Wilson?
- Yes.
- How are you Wilson?
- I'm doing good. (both laughing)
- Tell me about yourself.
- Myself. I'm born and
raised in Singapore.
My parents are from Indonesia.
Currently I'm a junior
at the University of Southern California
studying computer science.
- Very good.
How you have your
relationship with your family
and, you know?
- I'm really close to my mom.
- Okay.
- Actually just last week
I flew back to Singapore,
like just after finals ended
just to spend some time with my mom
and then came back here
'cause starting an internship like soon.
- So, what about like after school?
- I mean, the dream is, as
a computer science major
to obviously get a nice,
comfortable tech job, right?
- Yeah.
- Like something like Apple or Facebook,
something like easy.
- Oh yeah.
- And then,
but if it's real aspirations,
one day, like do a startup.
- Oh man.
- And you are?
- (laughs) Anthony.
- Anthony. Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
- Tell me about yourself.
- So, I'm born and raised
in Southern California.
I graduated in 2019 from
college with a bachelor's
in humanities, emphasis in
philosophy and theology.
Currently right now I'm
a high school teacher
at a private school in Orange County.
I'm also write too.
So, like my writing gets
published in a magazine.
I come from a big family.
I'm Mexican. (laughs)
So, we're really all about like familia
and got a great relationship
with my parents.
I mean, I owe everything to my parents.
- And yourself is?
- Hi. My name is KJ.
- KJ?
- Yeah. Hi, I'm an actor and producer.
I've just been kind of building my career.
Family wise, I have 10 siblings.
My dad was kind of a wild
guy in his early twenties.
He was a director in Hollywood.
So, he just had a lot of kids.
I'm close with about two or three of 'em.
- Is it real or you're acting right now?
(men burst out laughing)
- Can I have
you step over here please?
- Yes.
- And can you take that.
For now,
let's go to you.
You take her out, what are you gonna do?
- Well, to be honest, that
would depend on Nikki.
I don't know what she's
into, what her interests are.
So, it would be kind of
selfish of me to say,
"We're just gonna go here.
We're gonna do this."
- Okay.
- But kind of, what I
like to do (stammers)
Beach. Get some ice
cream. Go bowling, maybe.
- Anthony, right?
- Yeah.
- If you are in the
relationship with Nikki
how
romance are you thinking?
(Anthony chuckles)
- So like how romantic
would I be? I guess.
- Yeah. I mean, you know.
Sometime I don't wanna see like boring.
- Oh yeah, no, no. 100%
No, I feel like me,
at least in my past
relationships, I'm very romantic.
- Okay.
- You know, whether it's flowers,
whether it's a surprise
like dinner, surprise date.
I definitely like to give a lot of effort
into the relationships
and put myself out there
and make sure that she feels appreciated.
She feels loved.
- What about you?
I mean like, how soon you can
introduce her to your family?
- When I wanna date someone,
I always think about long term.
- Right.
- Because I don't see a point
if it's just something short, right?
Like the power of compounding,
same with relationships as well.
So, if I get a comfortable
feeling with Nikki
if I understand that she
reciprocates at the same time,
then I feel like I could
introduce to my mom
very quickly, like within
two months, probably.
- You and Nikki in the first date.
How you approaching her? Do
you believe in the first kiss?
(men giggling)
- No. I believe first date is the date.
You get to know them.
If it's gonna work out,
if you guys have that
connection with each other.
And then from that point on
you guys talk about how you feel
and what should be your next step.
What's the proper next step to take?
- Are you looking at
any kind of commitment
or are you just like, "Okay,
this is just like (beep)."
I mean like, just like other boys,
a lot of boys just like
going out and having fun.
All of my friends out there
they all have girlfriends
and stuff like that.
I just want to have one too.
- I'm starting to get
to the point in my life
where I am starting to think
about long term commitment.
I've been in a few relationships
and they've lasted like a year or two.
I'm looking for something that
I can see going long distance
or, you know, looking for
a stronger commitment.
- Not personal, but when
you're talking about, you know,
last few relationship,
how did it end up?
- I'm in college right
now, moving around a lot.
And I didn't realize that was kind of
causing some of the conflicts it was.
- Make some move right here.
Can you two switch please?
Yeah. I'm kind of happy with this.
- Short Kings.
- Short Kings out here. (laughs)
(soft upbeat music plays)
- I'm Nikki. Nice to meet you guys.
- [All] Nice to meet you.
- Forget ideal first date.
If we were to leave here right now
where would you guys take me?
- It's 11 o'clock I think
Tsujita hotel opens at 11, right?
I'm kind hungry right now.
Like some ramen.
- Like thrifting, you know?
There's stores, open.
Painting, something like that.
- Aw.
- I just saw Top Gun.
I wanna see it again.
So I just take you to see Top Gun again.
- We'd leave right now.
You'd hop on the back of my motorcycle
and we would go to
Venice beach or something.
- Yeah. (Nikki giggles)
- Walk the peer.
(Bad Boys Reply by Inner Circle plays)
- Aw.
So are you guys outdoorsy
types or like home bodies?
- [Men] Outdoors.
- Yeah. Like 100%.
- Like if it's like a group of friends
that all planned a trip
and can super like, "Oh,
like this weekend going
to Joshua Tree", like super down for that.
At the same time like
other weekends just
wanna stay back, right?
- So what are your hobbies and interests?
- I enjoy playing the guitar.
Sometimes write music.
- For me it would be
anything adrenaline related.
Doing such things as
like, if there's a swell
we'll go out and surf the big waves
or swimming in all the
ocean and off the boat.
Like whatever.
- There's not like a ton
of stuff to do in Indiana.
So, I found a lot of fun stuff
to go do with my friends-
- You're from Indiana?
- Yeah.
- Oh my gosh.
- Yeah. It's kind of far
but...
- (giggles) Just a little
- But you know, so we
we're always finding like
going hiking in the woods
or like going to a concert or something.
- I like to go jet skiing
and anything kind of beach related.
I love the beach.
I'm trying to get my pilot's license and
make that a hobby, just go flying.
- Ben, can you go to the first?
KJ and Youssef switch
and then Wilson to the end
and then you scoot down.
Or KJ to third.
Yes.
Wait, I have one important question.
Do you guys know your astrology signs?
(Wilson laughs)
- [Ben] Capricorn.
- Do you know your big three?
- I know that I'm a Scorpio moon,
Capricorn's like my like birth sign.
- I don't even know what
that means, to be honest.
(all laughing)
- Are you ready?
So, I actually-
- Do you know you're big three?
- No, I don't like a astrology signs.
- Oh, okay.
- Yeah, I'm a philosophy major.
and I have a whole report on
why I'm not a huge fan
of astrological sciences
but like the history of it's really cool.
- To be honest. I don't know
anything. I just wanted to ask.
- Oh. (laughs)
(Nikki giggles)
- Not gonna lie.
- I was like, "Uh?"
- I just wanted to see how you
would react to the question,
you know?
- [Anthony] Yeah.
Any past relationships
and why did that end?
- I had two past relationships.
The most recent one was
about three years ago.
She moved to West Virginia for school.
So, it wasn't really anything crazy.
- So, long distance not gonna work?
- No, no.
I'm too busy to even try to
make a long distance work.
- The most recent one was
throughout like the year of COVID
when like school's online
and then broke up like last year
just because like she's
was in a school in UK.
And obviously here coming to Cali
is gonna be in completely
two different places.
- I'm here for you, bro.
(Anthony and Nikki laughs)
- I have never had a past relationship.
I feel like I gotta work on myself
and get myself like fully comfortable
and happy with what I have
and what I'm doing
before I start putting my
time into someone else.
And I also believe like a
relationship comes after
a friendship, a really good friendship.
So, I never wanted to like rush anything.
Just see how it goes.
- Can you two switch?
And you two switch.
- Started from the bottom, now we're here.
- (all laughing) I know, right?
- Let's go.
- Dad's gonna come in and be mad.
- Wow.
(all laughing)
- Sorry, dad.
- It look like I'm upside out.
I mean like based on what?
- Personality.
- Okay. What else? Just personality?
- I put Youssef first
because I liked how like fun
and spontaneous he sounded
and stuff like that.
And I'm still young. We have fun.
- Well fun still, you
know, different but, uh...
But, yeah.
- And like we have a lot of similarities.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- I'm living life and having fun.
I'm not fully work, work, work.
So, I expected him not to like that.
And for the daughter right
off the bat, I was like,
"Okay, she's a fun personality.
Like she's most likely gonna
dig this whole vibe." (laughs)
- And then same with Ben.
- Mhm.
- Yeah. We have a lot of similarities.
I liked his date idea. (laughs)
Wilson, sorry.
- It's all good.
- I feel like we don't,
we're not vibing like that,
you know?
- It's a swing and a miss,
you know? That's what it is.
- Anthony, I liked your
career goals and all of that.
And then you seem really fun as well.
- Honestly, I think it was when I said
I wouldn't do long distance.
And then (plane crashes).
- Well, for now I respect
what your decision,
but you know...
- I feel like I'm not that
surprised with how you ranked it.
Of course you would choose
someone who was older
and knew what he wanted to do in life.
And then second guy still
at school, goes to USC.
But I feel like I came into
this with the mindset of
this is gonna be a fun experience
so let's choose like fun people.
- As a parent, expectation
is different than you guys
when you still young.
Been there than that so time will tell us.
- Would you let me hop on
the back of this motorcycle right now?
- Nope.
(Nikki giggles)
- She's kind of tough.
She want Boba, I will
take from Orange County
all the way to like
Hollywood just to get a Boba.
I mean, I willing to spend time
so hopefully you guys
willing to spend time.
Doesn't have to be that
high, but it have to be...
(all laughing)
- You'll never be close.